welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness dropped a new
trailer in recent days that apparently
has everyone wondering how evil wanda is
exactly though really i just think it's
the people of new jersey saying she's
evil while the rest of us know that new
jerseyans are safer and sitcom hexes
than left up to their own devices at
that action park anyway let's take a
look at this new footage and break down
everything you missed here we go
the multiverse
it's life or death
you could use an avenger
there are other avengers here i'll get
you back on the lunch box we got lunch
boxes can we sell those
whoa straight
depends on
no pressure then
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness tickets on sale this wednesday
i'm gonna buy some whoa the beast has
been released mr mess mouth from the
poster but is this fun or something else
i actually think something else and i
will explain why but first this moment
with wanda and strange in the orchard
the multiverse
it's life or death
i could use an avenger
there are other avengers we'll get you
back on the lunchbox this is actually
part of their conversation that we've
seen in other trailers
one day
i knew somewhere later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous now strange
says he's not here to talk about west
view but says wanda's help could get her
back on a lunch box acknowledging that
the people of west view are still
furious with her over her trapping them
in her hex so he's not saying i'm not
here to talk about west view as a way of
saying the events of one division didn't
matter he's saying they very much do
matter to everyone but i will not be
punishing you for it now by the way
there actually is a vintage marvel
superheroes lunchbox with spider-man
captain america and thor on the front
and then the fantastic four on the back
and then on the side scarlet witch
daredevil and yellowjacket and in that
one ovision post credit scene there was
a metallic container on the far right
side of wanda's porch that looks like it
might be an old-timey lunch pail and
since we know that this serene grove is
actually an illusion projected by wanda
that will warp into a red tinted
hellscape hell maybe they're in a pocket
reality inside that lunchbox i'm just
kidding that's crazy but also
kind of cool but a new shot of wanda
shows her floating in the mountainous
region surrounding camartage confirming
that it is her in that dark scary cloud
approaching the camera taj sanctum and
attacking it this new shot looks like
it's taken directly from all the other
shots of spells and magic ripping
explosions to the camaraderie courtyard
so why is wanda attacking this place is
this precisely our wanda because we know
wanda will split into two forms in this
movie one dressed in her scarlet witch
attire another barefoot and loungewear
who attacks the illuminati citadel later
i actually think these two forms were
first seen in the wanavision
post-credits scene one in sweats brewing
tea another an astral form in the
scarlet witch gear reading the dark hole
so i think these two may be initially
contained within wanda's body in the
first part of the movie but with dark
loungewear wanda at the wheel the wanda
controlled by kethon and then in the
seance and camartage after this battle
that may be where inside her head she
projects both these consciousnesses
inside wanda's westview house as we've
seen in the footage and that could be
the point that these two wand is finally
split into distinct physical forms one
pro avenger one just pretty pissed off
and trying to get her kids back this
trailer also gives us more footage of
the illuminati citadel battle a vibrant
explosion streams through the lobby as
the glowing mystery figure gets blown
back toward us the look of the explosion
itself is just nuts red tinted fire in
the center but then streaks of orange
energy beaming out like these are how
this mystery figure's energy manifests
the more i look at this figure it just
gets harder and harder to not see maria
rambo making her an alternate universe
captain marvel if it was maria call sign
photon who got hit with the space stone
powered light speed engine cosmic
radiation instead of carol danvers now
are you looking to set up your smell
game but not sure where to start well
scentbird is a flexible fragrance
subscription service that lets you shop
from over 600 brands scentbird lets you
choose a new designer fragrance to try
every month they have perfumes and
colognes and unisex options you can
discover new fragrances by taking a
simple quiz on scentbird based on your
preferences previous purchases and quiz
answers they'll help you find the
perfect fragrance this month i received
big fever by hermetica paper bold by
commodity and atlas by toomey paper bold
has a great sandalwood scent it's just
really earthy and nice i could
definitely see myself wearing this use
this cool dispenser system
so fancy it's it's really a good amount
of scent kind of like eight times the
amount of a normal sample and with each
fragrance you get a 30-day supply so you
can try out fragrances before committing
to a full bottle you can upgrade to
receive two or three products a month so
make sure to use new rockstars for 55
off it's just seven dollars for your
first month of scentbird available in
the u.s and canada in this section we
also see more of mordo swinging his
orange glowing sword in that same
chamber where the illuminati throne sit
on the dais behind him no one remained
seated in those chairs suggesting the
others might have fled or rushed into
battle or maybe to safety to their home
realities and mordo and maria stayed
behind to fight now while the cameos in
this movie are expected to be bountiful
they might not account for as big of a
wedge of screen time as say toby and
andrew got and no way home since it was
confirmed multiverse of madness will
have a run time of just two hours and
six minutes which is totally fine that's
still a pretty sizable movie and i do
think we forget how much of no way home
screen time actually went to
establishing peter's pr crisis and his
college entry struggles whereas by
comparison i think multiverse of madness
can really hit the ground running with
its plot but really the craziest new
footage shows wong facing this hulking
monster as a red flame bursts beside
them followed by this wider shot of wong
harnessing eldritch magic shields
turning them into swords as that beast
stands behind him but looking a bit
tired laying against the statue of
someone can't really tell but then the
camera pans over to the scarlet witch as
if all of them are teeming to face off
against something else now my first
thought was that this beast is just
straight up c'thon the elder god who
wrote the darkhold and cursed wanda with
her chaos magic when she was still a
baby they do look pretty similar because
i'm pretty sure this location is going
to be revealed as the darkhold temple
atop wundergore mountain thus the
carving on the back wall matching the
design of the scarlet witch page of the
darkhold and the horned figure on that
altar matching the horned figures on the
cover of the darkholds both of them
matching cathodon's alternate horned
appearance from the comics this is the
place where i think he wrote the
darkhold but there is a key detail here
that a lot of people are missing while
this beast can be seen behind wong there
is another one looking just like it in
the shadows behind wanda the issue with
that is kevan is really a singular
entity you would not see more than one
of him like this so rather i think these
creatures are actually the ingary and um
maybe don't attempt alternate
pronunciations of that the anger i are
elder spawn demons created by kefan
they're one of the elder races who lived
on earth millions of years ago who
enslaved humanity but were banished to
another dimensional plane they have
similar upper and lower sets of fangs
and an overall lovecraftian appearance
they're also known for having these
pitchfork tails which you can't really
make out here but just keep an eye out
for those because those are really going
to be the telltale tales if these things
are the ingary kathon would still be
very much a part of this story maybe the
threat that wong and wanda are now
facing it could be that loungewear wanda
could be the wander that still has
kython's possession inside of her as one
they're fighting now because notice
these two monsters eyes glow red as if
wanda is controlling them puppeting them
maybe weaponizing them against their
original master kafon and whoever he is
using as his avatar now of course the
way wanda is lit bright red it's just
hard to tell if she really is fighting
on wong's side in the scene or this
could be composited this wouldn't be the
first time marvel has digitally altered
trailer footage and hey according to
morbius the only parts of a movie's
trailer footage people care about could
just be completely left out of the movie
but the last new shot we gotta point out
shows strange or perhaps one of his
variants leaping on this taxi during
that gargantos battle on that jonas and
james building over on the far left
there's a sign that reads stanley center
perhaps a nod to stan lee because it's
similar to how they paid homage to him
in the 2008 hulk film with stan lee's
pizza the character stanley lieber's
name being a nod to stan lee whose legal
name was stanley martin lieber and now
that stan is no longer with us as they
did with his birthday on that cab and
spider-man no way home i'm sure they're
going to find all kind of creative ways
to work in some love to him in each of
these titles now a reminder that the
best way to support us here at new
rockstars is to check out our new moon
night inspired shirt limited supply over
at newrockstarsmerch.com
and thanks again to scentbird for
sponsoring this video click the link in
the description use the code new
rockstars for 55 percent off follow me
on instagram twitter at ea boss follow
me rockstar subscribe to nerox stars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you